- Ever since I moved to New York,
people are always asking me if I've ever
had a New York moment.
Like they'll say, "Oh my god
Aparna, have you ever had
um like, a New york moment?"
Well one time I saw a
black guy with a mohawk
walk by a white guy with a mohawk
and they both high fived,
so I made a wish, 'cause
I know how miracles work.
But apparently, that's not a
real enough New York moment,
'cause everyone's all
like, "No, Aparna, I mean
like a New York moment."
So I stopped and I thought about it,
and I was like, "Well one time I
saw a fresh pile of dog poop
with a used condom on top of it."
I know, I was there, and that's
when I came up with a game
called "Too much
information, or not enough?"
You're right, there are
no winners in that game,
you just start an Instagram account
and you keep it moving.
So then I started to think, maybe I never
have a real New York moment.
Then one day, I'm walking down the street,
we're not that different, you and I,
and I see a delivery truck
rolling down the hill
with no driver in it.
At first I didn't pick
up on it right away,
you know, 'cause it wasn't about me,
but then I saw UPS driver
running after the truck.
And I was like, "I went to college,
I know what's going on here."
The UPS truck was headed
straight for this guy
in a bicycle and it's like, "Game on."
Then, as if in a movie, the UPS driver
power jogs up to the truck,
does a lazy triple axel
into the driver's seat,
pulls the brake like an
old-timey train conductor,
and the truck stops just
short of the guy in the bike.
The guy in the bike looks
up at the guy in the truck,
they share this long moment,
and then I swear to you,
they both just shrugged!
As if to go, "New York,
what're you gonna do?"
I was like, "Seriously? That's it?"
But then this stranger
walking by outta nowhere
hands me this giant slice
of pizza, piping hot,
and I was like, "New York, I get the hype,
I get the hype."
(smooth jazz music)